hallo deutsche schule deutsch lernen mit
spaß hörverstehen ließ die frage hört zu
notiert die antwort korrigiert mit der
lösung
gehen wir nach dem unterricht noch in
die stadt ja gute idee wohin willst du
denn gehen was willst du machen
ich möchte ihnen so gehen und die tiere
beobachten
der vorschlag gefällt mir aber wie
kommen wir zum 2 kein problem ich habe
eine karten und wegbeschreibung sap ich
schaue kurz nach also in fünf minuten
müssen wir das tram 9 an der haltestelle
beim sternen platz nehmen
dann steigen wir bei der haltestelle
kreis aus und steigen in den bus 32 ein
bei der wexstraße steigen wir aus
danach sind es noch ca 150 meter zu fuß
bis zum 2 hallo mama wie geht's hallo
monika mir geht es gut danke und dir
auch gut danke du mami ich rufe an weil
ich mein altes spielzeug brauche
hast du mein altes spielzeug noch monika
das tut mir leid vor ein paar jahren
habe ich einer kinderkrippe das
spielzeug gegeben
ich habe gedacht dass du es nicht mehr
brauchen wirst entschuldige vielmals
bald er hat gesagt dass er einen
wirklich schönen geburtstag hatte sehr
schön das freut mich wenn wir gerade
dabei sind so martina sag mal weißt du
jetzt was du deinem mann zum geburtstag
schenken wirst ja ich weiß es ich werde
meinem mann ein gummiboot schenken
wirklich er hat diesen sommer die ganze
zeit gesagt dass es so schön
nun zu den wetterprognosen für die
kommende woche
dass der winter langsam zu ende geht
merken wir an den höheren temperaturen
auf morgen steigt das thermometer wieder
am morgen ist es zwar noch kühl doch
gegen mittag wird es fast 15 grad
wenn sie also morgens aus dem haus gehen
können sie einen leichten mantel
anziehen
trotzdem empfehle ich einen regenschirm
weil das april wetter wechselhaft ist
gibt es am nachmittag vielleicht etwas
reden
[Musik]
hey wie gehts
ich habe gehört jemand hat euch in
barcelona ausgeraubt stimmt das naja
nicht ganz ein taschendieb hat meine
cousine bestohlen
nein was hat er denn gestohlen
der taschendieb hat meiner cousine das
handy und den pass gestohlen
das war dann besonders blöd weil wir für
sie einen neuen pass organisieren
mussten die ganze woche mussten
hallo marco christ peter alles klar
hallo peter ja alles gut und bei dir ja
alles gut du ich rufe an weil du doch so
eine professionelle bohrmaschine hast
könnte ich sie vielleicht für ein paar
tage ausleihen
das tut mir leid gestern habe ich den
nachbarn im zweiten stock die
bohrmaschine ausgeliehen sie haben
gesagt dass sie die maschine noch bis
zum nächsten wochenende brauchen
du kannst sie aber gern nächste woche
haben wenn du willst
johannes kunz wird sie momentan bin ich
unter dieser nummer nicht erreichbar
ich bin bis am 9 februar in den ferien
wenn es unbedingt sein muss können sie
mich in meinen ferien stühlen auf der
handy nummer 0 79 34 53 sano schönheits
meister grüezi guten tag frau meister
mein name ist daniel smith
ich möchte meine haare schneiden lassen
grüezi herr smith gerne
wann möchten sie kommen am
donnerstagnachmittag um 14 uhr 45 können
sie am donnerstag um 14 45 kommen ja das
geht
herr daniel smith
waschen schneiden föhnen
praxis dr med kuster imhof guten tag
guten tag frau im hof hier spricht erika
meyer
wie kann ich ihnen helfen frau meier
ich möchte mich untersuchen lassen
wann haben sie sprechstunde die
arztpraxis ist von montag bis freitag
geöffnet
die sprechstunden sind von 8 uhr 30 bis
12 uhr und von 13 uhr 15 bis 15 uhr
entschuldigen sie wissen sie wo die
nächste bushaltestelle ist gehen sie bei
der nächsten kreuzung nach rechts dann
bei der ampel nach links nach circa 50
metern sind sie bei der bushaltestelle
gehen sie bei der nächsten kreuzung nach
rechts dann bei der ampel nach links
nach circa 50 metern sind sie bei der
bushaltestelle
weißt du wo mein handy ist ich finde es
nicht so habe ich es nur hingelegt ja
ich weiß wo es ist es liegt neben dem
kühlschrank
stephanie haben wir noch bier im
ja warum fragst du in einer halben
stunde beginnt das fußballspiel im
fernsehen
ich möchte während dem fußballspiel ein
bier trinken
michael du bist gestern als letzter nach
hause gekommen
du hast die tür nicht abgeschlossen du
weißt doch während danach muss man die
tür abschließen
kinder es gibt pizza pasta aber vor dem
essen die hände
hier ist ihr medikament nehmen
immer eine tablette nach dem mittagessen
kann ich die tablette auch vor dem essen
nehmen nein nehmen sie die tablette
nicht auf nüchternen magen sie müssen
zuerst etwas essen danach nehmen sie die
tablette hallo tina wie geht's hallo
lisa danke mir geht es gut aber mein
freund daniel ist krank er kann heute
nicht mit mir ausgehen
er liegt im bett und muss zu hause
bleiben
ach wie schade richte daniel aus dass
ich ihm gute besserung wünschen was
werde ich machen krank sein am
wochenende ist wirklich nicht lustig ja
das stimmt
entschuldigung ich habe ein problem wie
kann ich ihnen helfen schauen sie mal
meine pole ist nicht richtig
durchgebraten es ist noch wo das ist
gefährlich oh ja es ist noch rosa das
tut mir leid ich bringe das gleich in
die küche damit sie es nochmals braten
was hast du valentina fifi ja mein hund
yahoo
was hast du marina ich habe die c1
prüfung bestanden
was hast du gestern nach dem unterricht
gemacht weil ich habe im supermarkt
eingekauft keinen sport nein was
storm wochenende gemacht patricia ich
bin zu hause geblieben ich hatte
bauchschmerzen und dusche was hast du
gemacht
ich bin mit freunden ausgegangen wir
haben in einer bar bier getrunken hast
du gestern im kino ali und der film war
sehr gut sternen krieg 15
der ist der absolute science fiction
mega kracher mann
[Musik]
wie viele fragen hast du richtig
beantwortet schreiben die kommentare wie
viele fragen hast du richtig beantwortet
schreibt in die kommentare
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video
[Musik]